hello everyone and welcome to part
one of our two-part series tips and
tricks
to better histology in tissue based
research
a review of key factors influencing
tissue preparation and processing
i'm susie valdez of labyrinths and i
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots and
sponsored by leica
biosystems for more information about
our sponsor
please visit their site at leica
biosystems.com
so let's get started i want to remind
everyone that this event
is interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of your presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
that ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen i
now want to introduce our presenter
fiona tarbet a product manager at leica
biosystems in melbourne
australia for a complete biography of
our presenters please visit the
biography tab at the top of your screen
fiona you may now begin your
presentation
welcome
well thank you for the introduction so
today i'd like
to talk to you about um just some
different tips and tricks to
better histology and better quality
throughout the laboratory
so these are just a compilation of um
things that we have learned over the
long journey and hopefully you'll find
this a very informative
couple of talks
so first with disclaimer
this presentation does provide an
educational
material this is not intended to be
medical or regulatory or legal advice
so first of all i'd like to set the
scene
it's often really difficult as anybody
who's working in a laboratory whether it
be clinical laboratory
or in a research setting
to it's there's a lot of pressure today
there's often less time to think
problems through when problems do occur
and often problems are not necessarily
brought to your attention in
a timely manner so you may find that
there is a problem long after
the blocks are cut and the tissue has
been
stained there's more pressure
to react quickly and therefore quick
fixes
and the staff might be inexperienced or
not fully trained
those interpreting the sides may not be
the people that would actually
understand some of the problems caused
by incomplete fixation
excessive sized specimens or protocols
that are too short
you're often expected to do more with
less resources
there's an accelerating pace of
technological change
and monitoring maintaining and improving
quality under these circumstances
is a major challenge
so you do need to be thinking both
globally at a management level and
locally at a bench level to identify the
key factors
affecting quality so in simple terms
what we are trying to do every single
day is produce high quality sections and
stains in minimum time
from blocks that cut easily and are
stable and prolonged storage
with accurate identification and
labeling in minimum time
and consistently every day simple
isn't it so as a challenge
just think of six actions you would take
to improve the quality in your
laboratory
you can probably think of more than six
but what you can think about in terms of
the
actions are management actions and bench
level actions so the majority of this
talk will be on a more technical level
so we'll be talking about bench level
actions
but just to go through some of the
management level actions
to think about the staff recruitment
staff induction and training there's
staff accountability
and traceability who did what and when
staff shift fostering to make it
more interesting for people and also to
rotate staff through
staff task fostering ongoing
professional development
staff morale interaction of all staff
with pathologists or
senior scientists selection of
instruments and equipment
equipment maintenance reagent quality
and supply
lab layout conditions and workflow
all critical at a bench level
there are just so many different factors
that do affect technical quality
as you can see from the graphic on the
right hand side here we put together
just so many different
different factors from all the different
stages of your workflow
and these are probably just a few
there's probably a lot more that people
can actually think of
so today's webinar will be concentrating
on the pre-analytics
and up to the processing and
the next webinar we'll be concentrating
on the following process from embedding
through to cover slipping
so first of all here's a quote from
brace girdle
and this was sometime in the last
century but nothing has really
changed in this aspect if tissue is not
in a healthy living state when it is
fixed
it can only reveal abnormal details
whatever it's subsequent
treatment
so think about some of the pre-fixation
damage where this could occur
heat damage where forceps or
force absorb cautery happens and their
tissue is
left burnt if you like
so the mythology is lost tissue is
shrunken
desiccation often
tissue does not get fixed in a timely
manner or sometimes you might find that
the tissue is actually stuck to the lid
of your container fresh artifact
tissue is treated a bit rough roughly
and
it is partially crushed
auto assessed this can occur if
fixation hasn't happened in a timely
manner
so what can we do we can document
problem sources
particularly around cold ischemic time
that this is critical and is often
missed get the word out education
training
information sheets where people have to
actually list
how long the tissue is fixed for
at the time when it was put into
fixation
the role of the pathologist internal and
external communication
improve specimen transport if possible
think about what the role of the lab is
how are tissues treated when they
actually come into the lab
a large tissues automatically
opened and allowed to fix
what does the lab actually do
so fixation some common problems in
appropriate containers
inadequate volume of formalin poor
quality fixative
or tissue fragments that are roughly
handled so think about
the size of the container you should be
having
a container that fits the specimen you
should there is
generally a rule of thumb of 1 in 20
certainly no less than 1 in 10 volume
tissue 2
fixative the fixative
ph is critically important to make sure
that fixation actually happens correctly
some of the consequences of inadequate
fixation there's nuclear evacuation
you might have shrinkage and separation
particularly if the
tissue has been fixed in alcohol
there's formula pigment if the ph is
incorrect
or zonal fixation where the tissue has
not been penetrated
accurately and therefore the external
part of the tissue might be fixed in a
different way than the internal
areas of the tissue
again some of the consequences that you
might see on downstream processes
on the left you can see a breast tissue
where
there is uneven staining due to zonal
fixation
you can see a tonsil that has been
stained for a capa light chain
where well fixed tissue is showing very
strong
well-demarcated staining and
poorly fixed and weak reaction on the
right hand side
same tissue just poorly fixed
here we can see some of the differences
that you would see
if a tissue is correctly fixed in
formlin
or has had inadequate fixation in
formula
and is fixed in ethanol as you can see
there's quite a large amount of
shrinkage
but it's actually they look like
different tissues
we have the ability and many of these
slides we have created
internally so we've used the same tissue
just cut in parallel one fixed informant
and the other fixed
in ethanol and as you can see there is a
very
big difference between that fixed
informant and that fixed in ethanol
so what would make an idol fixative
nanofixative should react rapidly and
completely with tissue
fixing all the constituents without
removing any of them
it would penetrate rapidly and deeply
tissue would be stabilized to withstand
all the chemicals that are used later in
later processing
they should be minimally distorted by
swelling or shrinkage
should be hardened sufficiently to make
handling easy
and you should be able to perform a full
range of staining
methods and that would include ifc or
any molecular assays that are needed
tissue should be left in fixative
indefinitely without harm
and should be cheap non-toxic and
non-inflammable
unfortunately there is no such thing as
an ideal fixative
so a lot of what we need to do is a
compromise
and formalin is the world's most common
fixed fixative there are pros and cons
to form them
it is relatively stable it is relatively
cheap
it does favor basophilic staining most
stains
are possible though obviously with ihc
anyone familiar with that will know that
you do need to do antigen retrieval the
tissue consistency
is okay the tissue shrinkage is
acceptable
morphology is acceptable and prolonged
fixation
is generally okay but the cons are that
it does penetrate
slowly it fixes slowly it is unpleasant
and it's toxic not as good results with
acid dyes requires retrieval for hcn ish
if it is left in an unbuffered state you
can get formula and pigment
and it does require buffering
there are many commercial fixatives and
commercial non-formal infixatives on the
market
it's always good to be aware of what the
non-formal and fixatives are most
most people looking at tissue nowadays
are very familiar
with the artifacts that come with the
formal and fixation
there may be differences with the
different fixatives so always
understand what the fixatives are always
understand
too there are some for instance that
require
only up to seven days um that only lasts
up to seven days it might require
refrigeration
so yes just be very aware of their
choice
fixative so some of the fixation factors
so there's the rate of penetration and
diffusion and the rate of reaction
with formalin so it's often described as
the penetration reaction paradox
so while it does formalin does penetrate
relatively rapidly the actual fixation
is quite slow so first forming a
methylene bridge reversible with the
primary amines
and then more complex structures as
fixation continues
and this is why this is sort of the
basis of antigen retrieval
where the initial reversible
part of fixation allows us to retrieve
tissue so that
we can then perform ihc
so more in a clinical world
they do there are more and more rules to
try and standardize fixation
obviously in research this is an
absolute opportunity to try and
standardize
because it is just so important fixation
is continuous
fixation is necessary to happen
immediately if not immediately need to
understand just
how long that time was between when a
tissue was removed from a living
body and put into fixative so
again in the clinical world there are
rules about
between 6 and 72 hours so limiting it
on both the upper and lower ends
so just remember the basics with fresh
tissue
fix it as soon as possible if fixation
isn't possible
refrigerate but don't freeze freezing
can cause
the an artifact or ice crystal artifact
fresh tissue may be infectious
do not distort and label very carefully
so again the basics remember
proper penetration fixation the fixative
should penetrate from all sides so make
sure that your
container allows for that make sure that
your cassettes
allow for that the cavities should be
opened if you have a large
organ make sure that you do open
before fixation or if it's come in make
sure that you
inspect and open just to allow the
fixative to
get in perfusion of some specimens could
be advantageous
the thickness of the specimen is very
important
some agitation is useful just to
move the fluid around and allow for
diffusion
an adequate volume of fixative is vital
as i said earlier 1 in 20 is a rule of
thumb
certainly never less than 1 in 10.
sufficient time
is required for penetration and fixation
up to 24 hours as you can see the
six to 72 hours is given for breast
tissues
uh particularly if someone wants to do
uh
an er or pr which is ihc but
24 hours if you have 24 hours is
really considered ideal room temperature
is satisfactory but
heat will increase penetration but
remember excessive heat
during fixation might also cause other
other metabolic reactions to occur
so it's a balance 37 degrees would be
perhaps sufficient for fixation
heat again
the right choice of fixatives
carefully made up from reagents and a
suitable quality
and at the correct ph if you are making
up your own
um fixative it is really important to
understand exactly what the proportions
of the
salts if you're using buffett or to
realize what is going to happen if
it's if you're using an unbuffered um
formula formula is particularly
susceptible to
ph and as well as fixation you do need
that combination of the correct ph seven
um or slightly alkaline and
obviously fixed fixatives and are going
to be so affected by the ph
that um if it is more acid you'll not
only
start becoming formic acid and therefore
um having those artifacts but you would
also
the fix the fixation reaction the
chemical reaction just won't
occur many commercial formal and
fixatives do contain up to 10
methanol this is to stabilize them but
again
remember that if the commercial fixative
does contain
a large amount of methanol then the
ethic the will be
the alcoholic fixative first
and then the formula chemical reactions
so check specimens received in fixed if
and replaced if necessary
if a specimen has been in uh fixed a in
a fixative or form and fixed it for too
long
um again it starts become ineffective
as a fixative so you do need to replace
it
use only one spa for fun for primary
fixation
and if you do need to do a post fixation
step
then make sure that again it is
appropriate for what you want to
demonstrate
later on fixatives are also toxic and
irritant so be careful
so moving on to grossing
so getting the message through thick
specimens will not be properly
fixed fixed specimens process
poorly when normal routine schedules are
used
so how do you enforce this
on the right you can see some images the
most
routine cassettes are only about five
millimeters in depth so you do need to
um cut the tissue quite thinly and i
believe
in the us it's often considered the size
of a dime
is appropriate also with larger tissues
i talked earlier about opening cavities
this is another um a large
liver i think that we have actually what
we would call
breadboarding and that just means
slicing at appropriate intervals
just so that the fixative can get in you
could
really you can also soak paper towels
and put them within the
within the um sections that you've cut
and then sort of reform and reshape so
that you don't distort the tissue
but you also ensure that you get
adequate fixation
so think about some of the common
problems if a specimen is too thick or
too large for a cassette
because of the thickness the specimens
will not process using your standard
schedule
in extreme cases cassette bars will
distort
the specimen and you can see here some
extreme examples where a tissue on the
left
was actually too large when it was put
into the cassette
and has now retained the outside
or the the bars of the cassette as it
has shrunk as it has fixed
uh the middle shows that tissue often is
jammed into cassettes if it doesn't fit
in a cassette and then it's not going to
process correctly
specimen shrink during processing so the
cassette choice must always
allow for this we saw in the previous
slide
where the specimen was too large for the
cassette uh equally you must think about
is it is the tissue actually too small
is it friable
will it fall through the cassette ensure
that the
the cassette choice is the correct
choice
there's always a risk of specimen to
specimen contamination
if tissue actually um
if tissue actually comes through the
holes in the cassettes
so we've also
seen that for many different techniques
it is appropriate to use what we would
call a mega cassette
so mega cassettes are as you can see
there's an example
where at least twice the size of a
routine cassette
so this actually does create challenges
for
correct fixation making sure that we do
not treat
a mega cassette or a tissue that fits in
omega cassette
in the same way or fixed for the same
time it will need longer fixation
grossing we need to make sure that
we correctly grow so that it still fits
within the large cassette and again
particularly as there is so much
material that it isn't crammed in
and for processing and cutting you may
need new micro terms we may need new
equipment
so moving on to the next stage our
tissue processing
so what to look for when assessing and
monitoring processing quality
there's a theoretical approach to
optimized processing
advantages of batch processing based on
specimen type
and dimensions the causes of poor
processing quality
and getting the best results from your
tissue processor
so what are the effects of poor
processing so first of all there is the
macro effects
where the tissue has an unusual physical
properties at embedding
section preparation may be difficult and
blocks might deteriorate
rapidly then there's the micro effects
which is the physical quality the
section is poor
the tissue morphology is poor or the
staining quality
is poor
so just going through some of the
effects of poor processing
you might see this demonstrated by the
time you cut your tissue and as you can
see there
the tissue has not been processed
correctly leaving a large hole in the
center
it might still look in its native state
but obviously once you start to section
it
there is nothing actually on you are
unable to actually
section and you lose the tissue
you might see some damage like large
cracks which again
are shown on that slide on the right as
cracked
and lost tissue
here we can see some examples of poor
processing
not always what you might expect
this is a tissue that has been
inadequately um
in the tissue has been too large for the
processing protocol that we saw
so on the outside we can see that there
is
the tissue processing has been
reasonable
but as we move further into the tissue
we can see the
gross cracking because the tissue has
not been supported
and then in the very center of this
tissue we can
see that there is still remains some
water in the tissue
so that we have a number of different
effects in this tissue
where the processing protocol was not
long enough
to penetrate um to allow the reagents to
penetrate in to remove the water
but then also left sort of alcohol
within the tissue
and caused drying and cracking
so what you might see is when you're
preparing your section that the block
has poor texture
that it's not uniform it's not cohesive
the sections might compress or the
ribboning might be poor
again this is not the microtome this is
the processing
you might see when you are floating out
your tissue that the sections sweat
on the water bath the components
separate on the water bath or that the
sections are impossible
to flatten
you may also see that the block
stability
reduces on storage so that the specimens
start to shrink in the block
or the block contains opaque patches
which means that there's still
some residue solvent left in the block
we talked about the micro effects so
phys physical quality of the sections
you may see that the sections are
disrupted that they adhere poorly to the
slides
that they're cracked or that they're
uneven in thickness
the quality of tissue preservation
sections can show poor
nuclear detail they might show poor
cytoplasmic detail
some special tissue features can be
disrupted
fibrous elements poorly preserved or
preservation is not uniform
throughout the specimen
or the quality of staining
so the staining may not be uniform
nuclear staining can be poor we can see
in this example the there is still water
left in this
section and the nuclear staining is
almost completely disappeared
you're just seeing what we would
describe as a blue hue
the cytoplasmic standing could be poor
as it may have an effect with
alcohol or again in this instance here
we can see
that there is still a bit of water left
in that tissue affecting the cytoplasmic
stain as well
or that the extracellular components are
poorly demonstrated
so all of these could be effects in
different ways and it is a way of
assessing your tissue
to have a look at the different aspects
from physical quality
from the quality of the morphology but
also the staining
you may have poor staining because you
have poor staining
but often staining is an effect of the
poor pressing as well so really consider
what is causing
any sort of artifacts you see
so as a theoretical approach to optimize
processing
you really need to think about do you
need to separate
out your tissues you may have
small tissues that don't require long
processing protocols
or that your processing protocol you
have all the instrumentation that you
have
is has a slightly higher ambient
temperature
and therefore your protocol might be
optimally
um shorter for smaller tissues or
little fireball tissues you may also
have
medium-sized tissues which is sort of
optimally processed
say at around four to six hours
but then you may have large tissues
so how do they process i mean the larger
the tissue
the more time you need to penetrate into
those tissues
you might have more dense tissues more
fatty tissues
so you really need to think about what
is the what
your tissue type is and if you can
separate out or optimize the processing
for these tissues it is always a good
idea
so here's just some examples where we
might consider
one to two hours for a two millimeter
endoscopy biopsy
a slightly longer time for myocardium
we might see a wedge of cervix which is
quite dense
hard tissue and often a larger section
might be taken
and that would require a longer time so
there's sort of a minimal
acceptable quality
if you do need to put all of your
tissues in together just be
aware of where that line might be
so to optimize processing quality
you could process tissues in batch based
on specimen types and dimensions
the challenge is always to do that with
the number of
the number of instruments you have to
process tissues as well as maintaining
an effective workflow
so think about what instrument choice
you're having to satisfy demands
think about the workflow of your
laboratory and whether you can actually
optimize the workflow to fit in with the
needs of your specimens to optimize
the tissue process and quality
so another challenge so think of
listing 12 different causes of poor
quality processing
probably you could think again of a lot
more
so here is the sun that we prepared
earlier and as you can see
it is a can of worms
there's incorrect solvent there's a
specimen type there might be incorrect
fixation
there might be faulty dehydration poor
clearing for grossing under filtration
under infiltration process and
malfunction processes not maintained
properly
poor quality reagent inappropriate
cassettes
excessive specimen load scheduled too
long scheduled too short there might be
calcium in the tissue
or the temperature isn't correct so and
these
are just some
if the tissue isn't fixed before
processing
as we went through some of the reasons
for the fixation
you can see the effect of short fixation
then the processing will not be
will not be good the specimens are too
thick
poor grossing techniques or a tissue
that
no one can decide on which part not to
put in so they pull in the whole lot
into a cassette
the tissue is too dense for that
particular
protocol it's too fatty and it
again needed a special protocol to deal
with the fat
tissue contains calcium deposits
all foreign bodies such as sutures or
staples or synthetic crafts
always best to remove it grossing before
we get to the microtime site
the schedule was too short so specimens
were not properly fixed
or not properly dehydrated not properly
cleared
not fully infiltrated with wax or a
combination
of all of the above
the schedule was too long so tiny or
delicate specimens were
exposed to dehydrates for too long or
exposed to a higher concentration of
dehydrates too soon
and this is particularly important when
you have um
poorly fixed tissue as you saw earlier
in the presentation
if the tissue is fixed in ethanol rather
than formalin
it causes a great deal of shrinkage and
really a completely different picture
you could be exposed to clearing agents
for too long exposed to hot wax for too
long
high temperatures for too long or a
combination of all of the above
so really think about the proportions of
your
protocol not just
have it using any one size fits all
protocol
it's really important to think about
every aspect
as i said with the incorrectly
proportioned for the specimen
type you may have the insufficient
dehydration
excessive dehydration before clearing
insufficient clearing before wax
insufficient time in wax excessive time
in wax
and remember that the time in wax is
also
not just when the protocol finishes but
when you actually remove the tissue
from your tissue processor you may
process overnight having an
end time at six or seven in the morning
and then the tissue is not retrieved
from the tissue processor till
nine that is all extra time in wax
that by definition is still heated
so remember to think about that when
you're thinking about
your tissue processing protocols
there could also be a problem with
loading a processor
the wrong schedule is actually chosen
how do people know
which is the correct protocol make sure
your protocols are named very clearly
the baskets may be overloaded with
cassettes
the cassettes overloaded with tissue or
inappropriate cassettes used
you saw earlier that there are different
cassettes some
will be mesh some will have larger holes
think about your choice of cassette
must support the tissue but you may use
other things like papers or biopsy
pads and keep the same cassettes just so
that you get
consistent movement of fluid
there may be maintenance issues with
your instrument instruments
every instrument will need to be
maintained well
so make sure that the maintenance is
kept up
also make sure that we always use a
correct
reagent that when you do replace the
solvents if you're taking them out
manually that they go back in in the
right place
be careful of heavily contaminated
reagents
using recycled reagents of
unsatisfactory quality
recyclers will give recommendations on
how how pure the final product will be
so just remember most um recycling of
alcohols
the recyclers themselves would say that
their
product at the end is perhaps 98 pure
um remember that if you are using as a
hundred percent that you
um take that into consideration that
you'll now have two percent and then
maybe more
of um water in your final product
some people do make a mistake and purge
to start the cleaning cycle before
they've moved this remove the specimens
while never ideal that can be recovered
but just really make sure that there are
adequate processes within your
laboratory
so that this doesn't happen inadequate
training of staff often the people doing
the
changing the tissue processes are not
well trained on just how critical the
tissue processing
is to to the overall workflow
so make sure that they know how
important their job is
there's also a lot of different factors
that affect
carryover during processing and again
this is the calculation whether your
instrument actually
does calculate um correctly what the
concentration of reagents are
or whether you are changing reagents
based on
the time of the week or the
time somebody can actually come in to do
the
change or on the number of cassettes but
just remember there are a number of
different factors that will actually
affect the reagent carryover
so there is the number the type size of
the specimens themselves
the number and type of cassettes uh
cassettes that have got
more infrastructure if you like
might actually carry over more reagent
to the next
to the following reagent than a cassette
a more standard cassette
the drain time between the steps can be
important
the actual retort design reagent
viscosity
if you are using a xylene substitute uh
some of these may be more viscous than
xylem
so remember that in considering
uh the karaoke into the wax
the reagent volume the properties of the
previous reagent
if you have a lot of grated alcohols or
if you are having a format with fewer
graded alcohols remember that you will
be carrying over from the previous
reagent
reagent temperature is important basket
design
does your basket allow you to
[Music]
stack your cassettes in too tightly or
have you got springs which actually
allows for
more um fluid movement
the number of biopsy purpose and the
type of biopsy pads
so biopsy pads while very efficient at
holding small tissues in place
actually do carry over at least 10 times
the amount of reagent
as a standard cassette so remember if
there's a lot of biopsy pads that your
your reagents will becoming more
contaminated than you perhaps
are expecting
miscellaneous so a failure to fill
maybe specimens are left in the air for
a prolonged period
allowing drying to a care to occur um
maybe the specimen's been immersed in
particular reagent for an excessive time
such as wax when they're not removed at
the end of the run
specimens being subjected to excessive
heat could that be at the embedding
center
specimens being placed in contaminated
reagents
such as wax contaminated with formlin
think about
where you place your um your basket that
contains formula
does that sit on top of the tissue
processor dripping formula into the wax
it's important to think about these
things specimens can sometimes be lost
during processing if the cassettes were
not correct
so that's a total of 36 causes i'm sure
there's more
so as there's so many different possible
causes so what do you do
to analyze your problem so when faced
with blocks at a difficult dissection
the first question to ask is what was
different about that run that produced
problem specimens to the previous
successful ones if you've been using the
same
protocol for the same types of tissues
for a long time then it's probably not
the protocol
what's the intended schedule or protocol
actually used
does my problem affect all the specimens
in the batch or just a small number
are they all of a similar type are they
all from the same source
when my specimens at the very top of the
retort
do i know with certainty what has gone
wrong
often assumptions are made about what
might have gone wrong or
where the problem may be um really ask
do i know when my specimens processed
using the usual schedule that generally
produces good results
for this type of specimen is it likely
that the schedule was too long or too
short for my problem specimens
do i definitely know that the problem
was caused by the process of malfunction
did the software indicate any error
did a visual check of reagent bottles
help the levels
is there a possibility that an error has
been made when replacing solvents on the
processor or were any reagents
over their recommended purity thresholds
was normal fixation applied to my
problem specimens
so all of these questions acting as
checklists can really help you determine
what was wrong what has gone wrong
and if you remain uncertain as to the
cause of the problems
just gather as much information as you
can by examining your specimens
thinking about different possible causes
and thinking about the situation
as well so close examination of the
blocks can confirm
what you suspect may have happened and
your nose can help if there's still
solvent left in the tissue
it can often help to describe your
blocks too
so we often use words which like crisp
or crunchy or brittle
it's often better to be much more
descriptive
really think about your macro effects
really think about your micro effects
think about the terms you're using to
describe the tissue is it
um is there a or um
you know have you lost morphology what
is there
what does the nuclei actually look like
so
but we do use terms like crisp crunchy
brittle
shrunken shriveled cooked so some of the
reasons for this might be
it could be over processed it could be
under processed
um sludgy it could be under processed
with fat
over processed dry powdery
if there's heart fragments is it calcium
or other material
as well as a clearing reagent probably
under processed
soft and compressible under processed
so reprocessing can be done
but we really need to be careful about
how you reprocess
because remember you're coming from a
situation where your tissue
is not in a perfect condition
anymore so if it's over processed
reprocessing will probably not help
if it's under processed you can
carefully consider
what you need to do in order to um
proceed and there are different there
are different
methods to reprocess some of which might
be more suitable for others depending on
what has happened to your tissue
is the outer room satisfactory that the
sensor is poor used an earlier example
it's probably under processed
is there poor consistency poor
consistency throughout
maybe there's a problem with your
processing reagents or the
fixation is the outgoing brittle but the
scent is satisfactory
over processing there may be discrete
layers or areas that are poor
there could be under processing of
susceptible tissues you may have
a tissue that has got soft elements and
then quite
dense collagen perhaps
there is one where you needed to
consider the different type of tissue
and you know perhaps use a medium length
tissue processing protocol specimen
separated from surrounding wax
it could it be an embedding fault or is
it under processing
so as a final question optimizing
processing
we can look at these two examples both
are processed on an eight-hour schedule
one is kidney block a
and one is kidney block b but i will
tell you that it is
exactly the same tissue it is cut in
parallel
so it's the same source it's the same
kidney it's cut in parallel
they'll both put on an eight-hour
schedule so think of the
different steps that we just went
through in
what do i know what do i know and how
would i um
understand what has actually happened to
this tissue why is there such a
difference between
a really well processed kidney in block
a
and a pretty poor tissue in block b
so think about what your answer will be
what is the difference between these two
tissues
but i'll go to the next slide and let
you know
the difference was the block on the left
is three millimeters in thickness and
the block on the right was 4.5
millimeters in thickness
this is enough to change the appearance
of this tissue
and to change the processing so again
if everybody got that completely correct
then
well done but it is really worth
thinking and challenging your
suppositions
of what may go wrong during processing
so that's the end of this session um the
next session will be
continuing on from embedding to
come to um handing out the slides
um and we will be taking
questions at the end of the next session
so thank you very much for your
attention today i hope that it was
informative and any questions let me
know
thank you
thank you fiona for that informative
presentation questions that come
in during today's broadcast will be
answered during part
two of our webinar series airing on
thursday at
9 00 a.m pacific and 12 p.m eastern time
we want to thank you again fiona for
your time today and for your important
research
we also want to thank lab roots and our
sponsor leica biosystems for
underwriting today's
educational webcast you can view the
webinar on demand
and labyrinths will alert you via email
when it's available for replay
we hope you enjoyed today's presentation
and we look forward to seeing you on
thursday
for part two tips and tricks to better
histology and tissue based research
a review of key factors influencing the
quality of sections and stains
take care everyone be safe stay healthy
bye